all right let's run through the latest
over the last 24 hours related to this
potentially looming arrest a failed
former president Donald Trump starting
with there is a stunning new report from
New York Times reporters Maggie Haberman
and Michael C Bender that Donald Trump
is completely disconnected from reality
wants to be handcuffed if he is arrested
and seems to see most of this as no big
deal and something that will just
Galvanize his supporters in favor of him
to which to some degree I think is true
and I will get to it but the people
around Trump are telling the New York
Times
Trump genuinely doesn't seem to
understand the legal Jeopardy that he's
in here because it's not only one it's
not only two he is looking at
potentially three or more arrests and
indictments over the next couple of
months the New York Times article
trumpet Mar-A-Lago magical thinking and
a perp walk fixation those who have
spent time with Donald Trump in recent
days say he has often appeared
significantly disconnected from the
severity of his potential legal woes
behind closed doors Trump has told
friends and Associates he welcomes the
idea of being paraded by the authorities
before a throng of reporters and news
cameras he has even mused openly about
whether he should smile for the
assembled media and he has pondered how
the public would react and is said to
have described the potential spectacle
as a fun experience no one is quite sure
whether his remarks are bravado or
Genuine resignation about what lies
ahead if he is truly looking forward to
it he may be disappointed and part of
that disappointment is this paragraph
indicates is that even though often that
perp walk handcuffed situation happens
where law enforcement walks You by a
throng of reporters and they take
pictures of you in handcuffs with
someone like Trump you would expect that
it's quite plausible that secret service
would arrange with the court to do it in
a quieter and different way but I have
to tell you that this is very much a
reflection of Trump's narcissism there's
also a guardian article people that
explains Trump wants to be handcuffed
for his court appearance in the Stormy
Daniels case people close to the former
president said to be unsure whether he's
serious about wanting to do a perp walk
but he wants to be handcuffed he thinks
that that would turn things into a
spectacle and that that would be a
really really great thing a very common
narcissistic tendency as we've
illuminated and enumerated for you
before
narcissists tend to think that they're
always smart enough
clever enough smooth enough to escape
consequences for their wrongdoing so
when try it if indeed Trump is the
narcissist that we and many believe him
to be
and we remember other elements of this
remember during the Mueller probe he
wanted to sit down and testify uh even
though
um every single lawyer who got anywhere
near him said you absolutely do not want
to do that lawyers realizing that Trump
would just lie and lie and lie because
another trait of narcissists is they're
not going to be able to tell that I'm
lying they're not going to be able to
catch me in a lie so given that we know
that about Trump
he may realistically be seeing this
entire series of possible arrests and
indictments against him almost like as a
TV show almost like as an out of Body
Experience where it's kind of happening
to something else he's just playing a
character in the entire thing but he's
in control and he's always going to come
out on top now I do think he is going to
come out on top in the sense of
I do believe
that if there is one arrest and it's the
Stormy Daniels case and it's the weakest
of all the possible cases at least in
the Republican primary it will help
Trump
in the general election if Trump is the
nominee I believe the arrests are not
going to help Trump the Maga crowd and
many of Trump's more hardcore Ardent
supporters certainly will be galvanized
by what they will see as an unfair
politically motivated arrest if it
happens so in the primary I think Trump
will benefit from it but I think it's
going to hurt him in the general if
indeed he is the nominee and Trump again
because he's a narcissist
he has this idea that he'll always spin
it in his favor and what sources are
saying is he doesn't really have any
idea how serious all of this could be
how expensive all of this could be and
how damaging it actually could be in a
hypothetical general election where
Trump is the Republican domini in 2024.
this is not stopping Trump from
continuing to send bizarre lawyers on TV
and that's what I want to look at next
one of our continued sponsors is ground
news an app and website that Aggregates
local and international news sources to
show you how breaking news is being
reported around the world it has become
a go-to resource for me right now I'm
looking at a story about residents in
Ohio reporting medical symptoms after
the train derailment ground news shows
the headline from The Washington Post
owned by Jeff Bezos says East Palestine
residents should look to agent orange
victims the headline from The Epic Times
a radical right-wing Outlet says Federal
officials enter 500 East Palestine homes
after toxic train crash I also like that
you can sort things by factuality
location and bias check out ground news
for free at Ground dot News slash Pacman
if you find ground news as useful as I
do subscribe for unlimited access the
link is down below